- Ils sont déjà épuisés.
La route a été longue,
périlleuse. Mais elle ne fait
que commencer. Ce qui les
attend, ils ne savent pas.
Mais ce qu'ils laissent
derrière, c'est l'enfer.
"J'ai entendu les tirs.
Je ne croyais pas que c'était
la Russie qui avait attaqué
ma ville natalelelelle où j'ai
grandi, dans laquelle où je suis
née, où mon enfant est né,
dans laquelle nous avons vécu,
aimé, et dans laquelle j'ai
laissé mes parents, mes amis,
mes proches", dit Anastasia.
La Russie dit être en guerre
pour venir les sauver.
"Il n'y a rien de moins vrai",
dit-elle.
"Vous n'êtes pas venus pour
protéger, vous êtenununus tuer.
Vous êtes venus tuer des mères,
des enfants, des retraités."
C'est le coeur meurtri de voir
sa vie qui a volé en éclat dans
les bombardements qu'elle est
partie avec ce qui compte
encore, son chien et son fils
Kyryl, sous le choc.
"Je sais que c'est une guerre,
dit-il, mais je ne pensais pas
qu'elle allait éclater aussi
vite. Je me réveille
en me demandant s'il s'agit
d'un attentat à la bombe
dans toute l'Ukraine."
(fracas)
C'est ici qu'ils étaient encore
hier. Kharkiv est le théâtre
de bombardements, de tirs
de roquettes et de frappes
de missiles impitoyables,
depuis maintenant trois jours.
La deuxième ville d'Ukraine a
des airs de fin du monde. Au
moins 21 civils ont été tués
dans les attaques. Car Kiev
pourrait bien servir de
répétition générale pour ce qui
attend la capitale du pays.
Une colonne de chars d'environ
60 kilomètres est en route vers
Kiev, mais elle subit
des retards importants.
Les Russes sont à court de
ressources, selon le Pentagone.
Le carburant et les rations pour
les troupes leur font défaut.
L'armée ukrainienne publie de
plus en plus de vidéos du genre.
Des jeunes soldats faits
prisonniers ou qui se sont
rendus aux forces de l'Ukraine.
Ils ont tous en commun qu'ils
disent ne pas avoir su vers quoi
la Russie les envoyait.
Tantôt, ils croyaient participer
à un entraînement, tantôt ils
étaient convaincus par leur
hiérarchie qu'ils seraient
accueillis en héros.
Ici, on voit un soldat qui
appelle sa mère, en Russie.
"Peux-tu venir m'aider, lui
demande-t-il, ils peuvent
me libérer si tu viens en
personne."
(tirs)
Ailleurs au pays, dans l'Est
et dans le Sud principalement,
les combats s'intensifient
aussi. Marioupol, et le Donbass
sont assigées. Kherson,
une ville importante près de la
Crimée est maintenant passée
sous le contrôle des Russes.
(slogan en ukrainien)
En Ukraine, l'effort de guerre
est l'affaire de tous ceux qui
restent.
À Enerhodar, des travailleurs
et des citoyens de la ville ont
formé un véritable barrage
humain pour empêcher les chars
russes d'atteindre la centrale
nucléaire de Zaporizhzhia,
la plus grande d'Europe.
"Je suis reconnaissant et
stupéfait du courage et de
l'héroïsme de nos habitants, dit
ce travailleur. Ils sont sortis
sans armes et ont construit
une chaîne humaine de plus
d'un kilomètre de long."
Selon les Nations unies, plus
de 700 000 Ukrainiens ont déjà
quitté leur pays alors que plus
d'un million d'entre eux sont
maintenant déplacés à
l'intérieur.
Au poste frontière de
Krakovets, les heures qui
passent gonflent les rangs de
ceux qui vont chercher refuge
en Pologne.
C'est au dernier instant
qu'ils ont décidé de partir,
de tout laisser derrière. Dans
la queue, vous le voyez, presque
que des femmes et des enfants.
Les hommes, eux, doivent rester
derrière.
Les quelques hommes que
l'on voit sont les vieillards,
les étrangers et les pères
de familles.
Ceux-là n'y viennent que pour
des au revoir, remplis de doute.
C'est le cas de Roman.
Tout ce qu'il veut, c'est voir
son fils et sa femme, Anna,
en sécurité.
- Il peut pas partir.
- Mais pour vous, est-ce que
c'est normal qu'on dise
aux hommes de ne pas partir?
- Pour moi? C'est comme ça.
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire?
- "Il n'a pas l'étoffe
d'un soldat", admet Roman.
"Mais il fera sa part",
dit Anna.
- Est-ce que votre mari
va se battre?
- Peut-être, oui. Oui.
- Ça vous inquiète, ça?
- Oh, oui!
- Elle ne sait pas si elle
retrouvera son mari. "Mais
l'Ukraine va l'emporter", dit
Anna. Ça, elle n'en doute pas.
Ici Marie-Ève Bédard,
Radio-Canad